Every modern computer, when you get
right down to the bare metal,
is doing basically the same sort of thing.
I’ve said before that computers are just
overgrown calculators,
but how do you go from a simple calculator
to playing video games,
sending stuff over the internet,
or even decompressing and displaying
the millions of pixels in this video?
In short, what’s your computer
actually doing?
Behind me is a scaled-up version of a computer,
but we’re going to go much, much simpler.
If you take apart your phone or PC,
somewhere in the heart of it will a
Central Processing Unit, or CPU,
connected to all the other devices
that make it work.
Now, to show a really basic example,
we’re not going to use all those devices.
The first one we are going to use
is the clock.
With every tick of the clock,
our CPU goes through a step in what’s called
the “Fetch-Execute” cycle,
or “Fetch-Decode-Execute”.
This clock is slightly magic,
in that it ticks (click) every time (click)
I click my fingers. (click)
(click)
In the CPU I’m going to have three registers.
These are bits of fast storage where the CPU
holds values that it’s working on right now.
These are: a register that keeps track of
our instruction cycle,
another that loads our instructions from memory,
and an Accumulator.
The final thing we need in our simplified
computer is somewhere to keep the instructions
and any values that we end up calculating.
That is RAM, Random Access Memory.
We call it Random Access because it
doesn't matter when or in what order
the information is read or written.
So: that is our computer.
Let’s run a simple program.
All it’s going to do is count up.
The processor has three steps:
Fetch, Decode, Execute.
It will just repeat those on a loop,
that’s the one thing that’s
actually built into it.
So we need some instructions,
actually in memory,
so let’s load our program into RAM.
The RAM is also used to store our answers,
our outputs.
In the real world,
these would all be stored in binary,
but let’s not overcomplicate things right now,
let's keep them human-readable.
An instruction has two parts.
The first part is the instruction itself.
And the second part is usually
a memory address.
On each clock tick, the CPU will do
one of three things:
It will fetch an instruction from
a memory address.
It will decode that instruction.
And it will execute the instruction.
Round and round in a loop.
So it’s going to count up.
We're going to begin with a number,
and add one to it, over and over again.
(click) Fetch.
One clock tick.
The Program Counter is set to 0,
so the CPU fetches the instruction at address
0 in the memory
and puts it into the instruction register.
(click) Decode.
The CPU decodes the instruction.
The first part is the instruction,
and the second part is a location.
In our case, the instruction is LOAD
and the address is 6.
So we will be loading the value in
address 6 into the accumulator.
(click) Execute.
The CPU executes this instruction.
It takes the value at address 6,
and loads it into the accumulator.
In this case the value is 1.
(click) Fetch.
The program counter is incremented,
and the CPU fetches the next instruction
in the next bit of the memory.
(click) Decode.
The CPU decodes the instruction.
This time, it’s ADD,
and the address is 7.
So we’ll be adding what’s at address 7
into what is already in the accumulator.
(click) Execute.
The CPU executes the instruction.
We add the value at address 7.
In this case,
it's the value 1.
1 + 1 is 2.
(click) Fetch.
From the next memory location, number 2.
(click) Decode.
An instruction to STORE the value in the accumulator
into RAM, at address 6.
(click) Execute.
Now, notice that we are overwriting what’s
already there,
so address 6 now has 2 in it,
instead of 1.
(click) Fetch.
A new instruction: JUMP.
With a jump,
the next address we fetch from is the one
in this instruction.
(click) Decode.
So we’re going to jump to
address number 1.
(click) Execute.
The Program Counter is now back at 1.
The ability to jump, to loop, and to build
instructions recursively is one of the foundations
of computer science.
So: we're back up there.
(click) Fetch from location 1.
(click) Decode.
It's the ADD instruction again.
(click) Execute.
Our accumulator still contains the values
from before,
so: 2 + 1 = 3.
(click) Fetch.
(click) Decode.
STORE again.
(click) Execute.
Storing it into location number 6.
(click) Fetch.
(click) Decode.
(click) Execute.
And we jump again.
(click) Fetch. (click) Decode. (click) Execute.
(continues clicking) We're in a loop,
and we’re counting upwards
by one on every sixth clock cycle.
(stops clicking)
Our program, with these simple instructions,
doesn’t have a halt command,
or any way to interrupt it,
so it will just keep incrementing
that value by one (many fast clicks)
until the number becomes so large it can
no longer be held by the memory address.
How it breaks then… well, that’s a whole
other video. (stops clicking)
And my fingers are tired.
This is a very fiddly way to program a computer.
In theory, it can be
but at this level,
these instructions are just encoded
in raw binary data,
which is basically unreadable for humans.
So we can convert that base 2 binary
to base 16, hexadecimal,
at that level we call it machine code.
The next step up from that is a symbolic language
called Assembly, which is a bit more readable,
but it’s still close to working at that
bare metal.
The original "Prince of Persia" game was completely
programmed in assembly.
That is almost unbelievable to me:
painstakingly figuring out each pixel of animation
and encoding it into something that the computer
almost understands directly.
Programming like that is complex, and hard,
and prone to the sort of human error that
introduces massive security problems.
It is difficult to code and difficult to debug.
So rather than dealing with the messiness,
or, well, the pristine logic of machine code,
higher-level languages were developed as an
intermediary step.
Those languages handle all of that memory
reading and writing for us,
so all we need to focus on is
what we want the computer to do.
So, here’s my code:
just the same instructions,
phrased a little bit differently,
phrased for humans to be able
to read.
I specify a variable, X. I then write a function
that loops forever,
and each passing through that loop
I increment X by 1.
Once I've written that code, I then pass it
to a compiler,
which turns it into that
original machine code for me.
So when I run the program,
it’s loaded into the computer's memory,
and executed.
If I want to run it on a completely different
type of computer, a Mac instead of a PC,
I can compile it for that CPU instead.
But this still doesn’t answer the question
of how the computer is
doing something as complex as
decompressing and displaying this video.
The answer to that is:
speed.
At the speed I was clicking,
at the end there,
we were executing one instruction every couple
of seconds on one thread, one bit of the system.
A modern CPU executes billions of instructions
per second – gigahertz – on multiple threads.
But at the heart of your PC, or your phone,
there is still just a ticking clock and
a fetch-execute cycle.
I’ve used a password manager for years,
and if you’re techie enough to reach the
end of this video, you should too.
And I’m not just saying that because this video is
sponsored by Dashlane, a password manager,
and if you go to dashlane.com/tomscott, you can get
a free 30-day trial of their premium version.
Why should you use Dashlane? Well, first,
reusing passwords is a terrible idea.
If you’re like me a few years back,
then you’re reusing very similar passwords
that have a few letters changed,
or have the site’s name stuck somewhere in them.
It’s not great.
One data breach at one of those sites, and it’d be time to start worrying.
These days, Dashlane sits in my browser,
and when I want to log in somewhere,
I unlock Dashlane with the single
password that I have to remember,
and it autofills it for me.
Dashlane also stores and autofills credit cards and
address information across your devices,
and it’s got a VPN to encrypt your traffic on public wifi networks if you want to.
If you are the kind of person who can remember
20-character unique symbol-filled passwords
for dozens of different sites, congratulations.
But if you’re not superhuman,
then your choice is basically:
use insecure passwords or
use a password manager.
Now, you could use post-it notes on your
monitor as a password manager…
or you could use Dashlane,
which generates, stores, and autofills
long, secure, different passwords for every site.
I don’t have to try and type in a 20-character password
filled with symbols on my phone any more.
I pull up Dashlane instead.
Everything just works, synchronised on all my devices,
across Windows, Mac, iPhone, Android,
all automatically.
It plugs into Chrome, Firefox, Edge,
Safari, Opera, even Internet Explorer.
And despite the fact that it’s all
synchronised in the cloud,
Dashlane themselves don’t know what
those passwords are
and based on their security architecture,
can never find them out.
I’ll explain that next time.
So: dashlane.com/tomscott for a 30-day
free trial of Dashlane Premium,
which includes unlimited password storage and sync.
And if you like it, you can use the code
“tomscott” for 10% off.